back by not so popular demand meaning
about one third of my viewers love these
videos and the other two-thirds are like
it's another episode of mystery
languages I will give you some samples
of a language and you have to guess what
language it is you might not be able to
guess the exact language but maybe
you'll be able to guess the language
family or the region or country where
that language is spoken or something
like that
just try to see how close you can get
language number one please listen Cheryl
you did he move your colitis ammonia
disowned me despite Oh retain at yeah I
dunno lasso
but ammonium even is Sumathi me hear me
children Willie Cauley lady Abubakar
more poison Oh believe me sister go come
back Yabba OCC Shaco hey Shaco and you
no more pink or ti dissing me she a
wooden bat me it was in a caballo very
very now let's see a written sample of
that language
so what language do you think it is
the language is yoruba yoruba is a
member of the niger congo language
family and is spoken in the West African
countries of Nigeria and Benin as well
as Togo it's an official language in
Nigeria and is spoken by an estimated 30
million people current estimates are
based on population growth since 1990
when 18 million people spoke it as a
native language it's also the most
widely spoken
African language outside of Africa
spoken by migrants around the world
that's excluding Arabic which is not
considered a native language of Africa
Yoruba is primarily the language of the
Yoruba people but not all Yoruba people
speak the Yoruba language yoruba is a
tonal language and each syllable has one
of three tones hive mid or low and as I
understand it you can hear these three
tones in the name of the language which
is pronounced Yoruba with a mid low and
high tone I probably just slaughtered
that pronunciation but you get the idea
there are three tones another feature to
notice is that Yoruba syllables consist
of a vowel a consonant followed by a
vowel or a nasal sound that functions as
its own syllable there are no consonant
clusters and in that regard it's similar
to Japanese alright let's look at
another language please listen
well Yanagi sushi ho dish oh I don't
know bit oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] Sean de todo be
eager hey this is a teeny husband Alicia
Nagiko jaboney non ya que up in the head
on Yoko don't need la cosa que onda I
don't know because you say it's Cabana
Hotel she had a piece of naughty jerky
on the Linda honey told it even
unanswered now let's see a written
sample of this language
now what language do you think it is
the language is Navajo Navajo is a
member of the southern branch of the
Athabascan language family it's one of
the most widely spoken Native American
languages with around 170,000 native
speakers most of whom are bilingual and
speak English as well the area where
Navajo is spoken is in the southwestern
United States principally in Arizona but
also across the state borders in New
Mexico and Utah Navajo is a tonal
language with four tones high low rising
and falling it has a large inventory of
consonant sounds
one example is a distinction between
plane stops and fricatives and labial
stops and fricatives for example there's
the plane stop cut and there's the
labial stop quo the difference is that
the labial sounds include the rounding
of the lips
another example is ha and ha and ha and
hua these two sounds ha and our sounds
not used in English and then we have the
labial sounds as well those are just a
few of the many sounds of Navajo ok time
for the next language to talk or man
your hotel vida es que da sector must
capture because OSAC has a whole soy to
tie Costa to Cassio Tico's which Pam and
at all don't attack he left was escorted
orientation never taught on at all
geography that could be Minister Academy
summary on benefit some shippers what I
wanna [ __ ] you an officer Tucker Santa
Catarina de cocora zucchini and kazoo
Kootenai Inca or 9/11 Kathy shaman on
our team a bond so instead of an
imminent get back on something or oh
yeah
now let's see a written sample all right
what language do you think it is
it's the Hungarian language Hungarian is
spoken by around 15 million people most
of them in Hungary in Central Europe but
some live in neighboring Romania as well
as other nearby countries like Slovakia
Slovenia Austria Serbia Croatia and
Ukraine Hungarian is not an
indo-european language it's a member of
the you Rick branch of the Uralic
language family one notable feature of
Hungarian is that there are lots of
geminated consonants geminated meaning
long consonants that are held longer
than a short consonant these are
represented in writing by double letters
in the audio sample you can hear this if
you pay attention for little pauses when
the consonants are lengthen another
notable feature is palatalized
consonants such as J key yeah G and yeah
Enya an overly simple way of describing
these sounds is to say that they sound
like the consonant followed by a u sound
I hope you liked this episode of mystery
languages if you haven't seen the
previous four episodes be sure to check
those out they're pretty much the same
as this one but with different languages
be sure to follow Lange focus on
Facebook Twitter and Instagram and once
again thank you to all of my patreon
supporters especially these ones right
here on the screen who are my top tier
patreon supporters thank you for
watching and have a nice day